hey everybody its charlie we just got a
whole bunch of new details about the
night king and Viserion as of the end of
season 7 they completely recontextualize
what happened in the way they're going
to be using him during season 8 so we
got to break it down
there's no spoilers for season 8 in this
this recontextualizes a lot of things
but it gives you better information for
theory crafting for season 8 so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Game of
Thrones videos there's a new round of
that 4k blu-ray giveaway - all announced
a new winner at the end of this the big
thing that just happened is the Game of
Thrones was submitting for Emmys they
had to submit some of their scripts
they're a bunch of extra passages for
torment scene when he's standing on the
wall here they clarify what happened to
him when he's leaving they give you a
better idea for how he probably survived
I think we all believe that he and
Barracks survived but the script even
though there's no dialogue that where
the characters actually say it it
actually clarifies what happens to them
in the scripts torment is thinking
internal monologuing about the night
king and Viserion and it completely
recontextualizes it with a whole bunch
of new details there are two different
parts of the script that do this so I'll
talk about the night King and Viserion
part first just because that's the
bigger one this is the script for the
finale and this is torment on the wall
in this scene right here watching as the
night king of Assyrian come flying in
and it reads but then a stranger sound
comes from the north tormund looks to
the sky and sees a moat on the horizon
it's moving fast so fast we don't get a
clear look at it or the night king on
its back before it's upon us then it
flips to this part here where you're
north of the wall staring at it as the
night king comes to bring it crashing
down it reads vissarion is hitting the
wall with a blast of blue flame brans
meaningful Birds take flight in a
massive chunk of the wall breaks free
ahead of tormund the ice dragon glides
away and we get our first clear look at
him and at the night King on his back
he's done the same thing to Viserion
that he did to Craster's Suns only those
were babies and this is a dragon so
immediately like that last part is
probably the most important one this is
what everybody's kind of freaking out
about a little because it doesn't
totally make a lot of sense but
try to explain what's going on because
what the show is saying in this script
is that vissarion is just like the White
Walkers like instead of being an undead
white that's reanimated and just
controlled by the night king like a
finger puppet he actually has a will of
his own most people have noticed that in
previous seasons the show has already
broken its own internal rules about how
the whites in the White Walkers work
there is no precedent for ice dragon in
the book that might be what the
cliffhanger ending is for the winds of
winter book but we won't actually be
able to verify that till the book
actually comes out which could be next
year you know who knows when that's
gonna happen but the only way that works
is that he's an actual white Walker is
as if he was alive when the night king
turned him because that's not exactly
how his power works so the rules for
White Walkers and whites are that the
night king is the only person who can
create new White Walkers all of the
White Walkers that we've seen on the
show are Craster's sons that he
sacrificed to him that was what that
scene during season four was I guess
because they're trying to say that
vissarion is like a white Walker they
want to have parity with this scene here
where he pulls him out of the lake
touches him and turns him the way that
he turned one of Craster's sons with
exception for the ones that bran and
John killed in the last couple of
seasons most of these are babies that
were born within the last seven years
because you remember all of Craster's
wives like they were almost constantly
pregnant so anytime there was a son he
would just offer it up to the knight
king so nigh King touches the baby turns
it into a white Walker with his power it
matures extremely rapidly maybe within a
couple years maybe even quicker than
that
so the real benefit to him turning new
White Walkers is that it's sort of like
him creating acolytes that can then
raise armies of their own so the army of
the undead multiplies that much faster
but I think the main reason why the show
wants Viserion to be like the White
Walkers is so that it's not like a
mindless zombie that just can only do
one thing at a time and it wants to have
a really significant moment with
Daenerys and the other dragons when
they're all fighting each other during
season eight the other practical reason
for it to be a white Walker and not just
a white is is it the whites decay like
they're almost be no internal organs by
the time they get to their final battle
and it wouldn't actually have the
biology to produce flame and that's
another thing here too they also clarify
that he's actually bring
being flamed to bring down the wall it
wouldn't make sense if he were breathing
ice it wouldn't be hot enough to melt
the wall so I think most of us assumed
that he was breathing flame but that was
one of the biggest things that people
talked about like wow this looks cool
but hey it totally does not make sense
there are holes in his wings how is he
still flying what's going on here so if
you want a nitpick you could actually
say yeah it looks like he's decaying and
it definitely looked like he died when
he went into the lake the only way that
really makes sense is if he was on the
edge of death when they pulled him out
of the lake on the chains I don't think
any of Craster's sons would have any
loyalty for him if they were to run into
him the difference in the dragon is is
that it was actually fully matured when
it was turned so they probably just want
to have a really WTF moment when
Daenerys sees it for the first time and
it recognizes the other dragons but
because vissarion has all of his
cognitive function he can actually make
decisions independently of what the
knight King wants him to do otherwise
all the whites only act when they're
told to do so by the white walkers and
they can only do one task at a time and
they'll just dash themselves against
whatever obstacles in front of them
until their absolute nothingness like
this moment where they throw the rock
here and it seems like the white
actually makes a decision here that's
really the knight King and the White
Walkers forcing it to do that normally
whites won't have that ability but it's
another good example of the show wanting
to have a really awesome holy crap TV
moment without it totally making sense
like please don't poke holes in this
because normally the white would just
stand there and wait for the White
Walkers to tell them to attack
[ __ ] the other big scene that was in
that script that tells you what happened
to torment when he was running down the
wall here and sort of implies that he
survived goes like this so it just reads
as like the wall is crashing down
tormund and barrack lead their Wilding
comrades to the stairs carved in the ice
Eastwatch has a massive zigzag stairway
not an elevator like Castle black they
run for their lives and disappear from
view so in this moment like all you see
is just like all this ice coming
crashing down on top of them while
they're all running down so it's really
hard to pick them out because it's
really dark but because the characters
are so important and because the actor
torment was seen coming to the set like
everybody just kind of assumed yeah he's
definitely gonna survive they're not
gonna kill him off screen like this but
it does let you know that he didn't run
the other way on the wall because there
are multiple ways to escape in a
situation like that but you can just run
along the top of the wall till you get
to Castle black or you could run down
those stairs now we know he and Barret
just barely made it out they'll probably
show up on Winterfell doorstep barely
alive screaming about the knight king's
army that's coming normally what you
would do with characters like that is
that you would have everybody meeting at
Winterfell preparing for battle because
they know that something is coming
you'd have torment and barracks show up
to freak everybody out and say that they
were right around the corner you thought
that you had a week to prepare no
they're here already but the problem
with that is that you have bran who can
effectively see anything like he is the
Eye of Sauron through his birds he can
see anywhere in the north that he wants
anywhere that his birds fly or anywhere
that there's a weirwood tree so he is
probably already told people about the
night king breaching the wall so they're
already preparing but again just a
really cool reason why it's important to
read the scripts when you do have the
opportunity because it can clarify
moments like this also really helpful
for more intrigue based plots where you
have characters thinking things up in
their heads like we don't get that
internal monologue on the show
so like the Littlefinger arias onca plot
was really unclear about what characters
knew how smart Littlefinger was who was
duping who liked his little finger less
clever than Arya and Sansa like that was
really hard to believe so normally in
the books you would get an internal
monologue so you would hear what Sansa
and Arya are thinking or what
Littlefinger is planning but on the show
you just kind of have to assume based on
the actors
performances in the way that they cut
the scenes so post all your reactions in
the comments below I'll say
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Sara DJ 104
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details not confirmed longer than an
hour but most people have been saying
that people associated with the
production so the assumption is yes they
will all be feature-length episodes but
click here for my new Jaime Lannister
video and click here for my breakdown of
that season 8 panel and the spin-off
panel where they explain what's going on
with that new show thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight